welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka Zack spoiler
and there's been a new update on the
Snyder cut this dropped this morning
from Zack Snyder himself and the
director put out a cryptic statement on
the release of his original vision of
Justice League before we get into the
story make sure you subscribe to the
channel for breakdowns and updates like
this every day and if you enjoyed the
video then don't forget to leave a like
anyways Snyder has been running a
competition on his Bureau account
recently and the prize was a clapper
board that was used on the film however
why this has been getting hotter than
whatever Alfred gets up to whenever
Bruce leaves the cave at night it's
because of what's written on the board
there are two messages on it that have a
lot to unpack from them and I'll read
them out and show how they can be
interpreted so the first side which
tends to detail what is being shot that
day say something cool with Batman
Superman Louis or Martian Manhunter when
justice cut was released there were a
lot of rumors that Martian Manhunter was
going to be in the film and Snyder has
pretty much confirmed numerous times
that the character was indeed going to
be making his DC debut in the movie the
scene was planned but never actually
shot and this clapperboard could be
paying lip service to the fact that it's
going to be added whether this is true
or not we don't know but either way it
once more solidifies that he was going
to be in the film and what's interesting
is that it's teasing additional
photography on the movie now we know for
definite that a Snyder cut those exist
whether you wear a tinfoil hat or not I
think everyone knows the basic principle
of movie editing and that is that
multiple cuts of a film tend to be
produced the studio looks at them makes
their decisions and decides what needs
to be cut added reshot the whole shebang
before things are finally released
because they brought in Joss Whedon to
do reshoots after Snyder's vision of the
film had be made shows that there would
have been a finished vision that they
may or may not have liked which judging
by reshoot was probably the latter
that's just a basic principle of
moviemaking and there probably exists
multiple versions of Justice League that
all have some scenes in there Kurt's
that are not another's release the miles
Dyson cut you cowards so yes a Schneider
cut definitely will exist but whether
this has CGI completed and can be
released as a finished product is
another matter entirely
Schneider previously confirmed that his
version of the film was 214 minutes long
so in order to have this run time that
would have to be something in place even
with this though people that worked on
the film have come forward and said that
additional work does need to be done in
order to complete it so yes this
clapperboard could mean that there is
another scene being shot or it could
just be something that zack snyder has
written with his tongue in his cheek on
the back of the slate the following
message can be seen please extend to the
bearer of this slay the right to pass
all security protocols and the
permission to operate this motion
picture scene and sync marker on the set
of any additional photography for the
motion picture and known as Zack
Snyder's Justice League in the unlikely
and purely speculative events that
search photography is needed Zack Snyder
thanks for putting a full stop in there
Zack anyway basically on the back.this
Slade grants the competition winner
access to the studio to come and watch
the additional scenes be filmed they
also get it operate the clapper board
and shout action we don't know that for
definite but we've got this covered said
it was happening so it's definitely
happening you can really take this
statement one of two ways and this is
mainly because of the line in the
unlikely and purely speculative event
that such photography is needed the fact
that it says unlikely well means that
it's unlikely that this filming will be
done and therefore the Snyder cut will
not be released however the following
purely speculative teases to me a bit
that he's playing up that people think
that this may be happening but is it we
don't know now as I've said earlier I do
think that a version of the
quote-unquote Snyder Co exists however I
think Zakia is trying to build up hype
for the movie further in the hopes that
the studio finally listen to what fans
want for the meantime I think this
cryptic message really can be taken
either way and I have seen some people
saying that it means it's confirmed and
others saying that this completely
shoots it down it really does neither to
me and if a Snyder Kurt or does not get
released I think you could point out
this in
well this told you months ago as for its
release on HBO max we have further
rumors that have floated up since this
that say the project will be released on
the streaming service which is going to
be showing a multitude of DC movies
there's been steady escalation on the
film's release ever since we found out
about it and even on the two-year
anniversary of the film's theatrical
debut hashtag released the Schneider
Kurt trended worldwide as for the moment
AT&T have yet to comment on the
situation but there's a lot of outcry on
the internet for something to be put out
personally I think that HBO max is the
perfect platform to release the
snedecker on and if the streaming
service is looking for day one sign ups
and this is the best thing that they
could drop now whether they will or not
remains to be seen but for the moment
there are still things circulating about
it I actually don't think that it will
release on HBO max just because I think
Warner Brothers are a bit too stubborn
on it and that they're purposely
sticking their head in the sand about it
which is why we've never had an official
statement on the project eventually
though I do think we will see a release
of it much in the same way that we got a
Richard Donecker of Superman - let's
hope it doesn't take 20 years to release
because I would love to be proven wrong
on the HBO statement and to have Warner
Brothers make me look like an idiot
which which isn't hard let's be honest
anyway that's all of the updates we have
on it and obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on why do you think the
stylet code will be getting released and
what you take from the cryptic message
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please give it a
thumbs up and make sure you check out
our full breakdown of what was going to
be in the Snyder coat which is gonna be
linked at the end we go over the entire
plot of the movie so it's definitely
worth checking out if you want to know
more every month on the 15th we give
away free blu-rays and all you have to
do to be in with a chance of winning the
Infinity Saga box set is leave a like
and subscribe with notifications on you
want to support the channel and get to
see content early then please consider
clicking the join button you can also
come chat to us in our discord server
linked below or at definition whitey on
Twitter those are the best ways to keep
in touch so hopefully we see over there
very soon
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you